AS ALWAYS, SHE HAS A GREAT SHOW.
>> LAURA: HELLO, EVERYONE, IN
THE THE "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
CLAUS AND THE GAME.
THAT'S THE FOCUS.
THE ASSOCIATED PRESS, WHICH WAS
ONCE CONSIDERED THE GOLD
STANDARD IN REPORTING, IS NOW
LITTLE MORE THAN A GLORIFIED
PRINT VERSION OF MSNBC.
THEY HAVE GONE FROM KEEPING
POWERFUL INTERESTS IN CHECK TO
PROTECTING THEM AT ALL COSTS.
SO WHEN THE GLOBALISTS AT THE
WORLD ECONOMIC FORUM NEED COVER
THEY KNOW WHERE TO TURN.
THE POOR BILLIONAIRES, ALL THEY
WANT TO DO IS KICK AROUND THEIR
PLANS FOR SAVING THE PLANET,
AND, INSTEAD, THE A.P. SAYS THE
EVENT HAS BECOME A TARGET OF
BIZARRE CLAIMS.
FOR THOSE WHO BELIEVE A GROUP OF
ELITES ARE MANIPULATING GLOBAL
EVENTS FOR THEIR OWN BENEFIT.
THE GREAT RESET HAS BECOME
SHORT-HANDED ON TALK SHOWS FOR
WHAT SKEPTIC SAY IS A
REORGANIZATION OF SOCIETY.
I HATE TO BREAK IT TO YOU BUT
THE TRUTH IS NOT A CONSPIRACY.
WHAT DOES THE WORD "RESET"
REALLY MEAN IF IT'S NOT A
REORDERING OF WHAT CAME BEFORE?
I WAS TRYING TO ADD UP THE TIME
EARLIER TODAY BUT I THINK IT'S
FOR MORE THAN 20 YEARS NOW I'VE
BEEN REPORTING ON AFAR FROM
DAVOS, BUT NOW THEY ARE
APPARENTLY OFFENDED WHEN WE'RE
LITERALLY JUST QUOTING THEM AND
PLAYING THE VIDEOS THAT THEY
HAVE POSTED ONLINE BECAUSE,
LOOK, IF YOU QUOTE THEM AND POST
VIDEOS, IT'S ALL DISINFORMATION.
APPARENTLY THEY HAVE
MYSTERIOUSLY REMOVED SOME OF
THEIR MORE CONTROVERSIAL VIDEOS
RECENTLY.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT THIS QUESTION
OF DISINFORMATION, I THINK IT
MAPS BASICALLY TO EVERY OTHER
MAJOR CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE
GRAPPLING WITH AS A SOCIETY AND
PARTICULARLY THE MOST
EXISTENTIAL AMONG THEM.
CONSPIRACY, PROPAGANDA, CLICK
BAIT, YOU KNOW.
THE BROADER MIX OF BAD
INFORMATION.
WHAT IT ATTACKS IS TRUST.
>> LAURA: WHAT THEY DON'T SEEM
TO FATHOM IS THAT THE ELITES
BROUGHT THIS ON THEMSELVES.
THE REASON THE PUBLIC DOESN'T
TRUST THE MEDIA ESTABLISHMENT
LIKE THAT GUY OR THE CORPORATE
ESTABLISHMENT, PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTABLISHMENT, IS BECAUSE NEVER
LONG AGO CEASED BEING HONEST
BROKERS.
THEY HAVE BECOME RANKED
PARTISANS AND COMMITTED
GLOBALISTS.
SO HOW IS IT THAT A BUNCH OF
BRAVE DOCTORS WERE THE FIRST TO
EXPOSE THE PROBLEMS WITH THE
M-RNA COVID SHOTS?
WHY WAS THE BIDEN STORY
DISMISSED OUT OF HAND?
THE ELITES AND OUR OWN MEDIA
DON'T LIKE YOUR FREE SPEECH
BECAUSE IF YOUR VIEWS ARE
CONTRARY TO THEIRS AND
PASSIONATELY EXPRESSED IT WILL
BE DESCRIBED AS DISINFORMATION,
MISINFORMATION, CONSPIRACY
THEORY OR THEIR FAVORITE, HATE
SPEECH.
AND THE EUROPEAN COMMISSION FOR
VALUES AND TRANSPARENCY WANT
THEIR RULES TO APPLY HERE.
>> WE NEED THE PEOPLE WHO
UNDERSTAND THE LANGUAGE AND THE
CASE LAW IN THE COUNTRY, BECAUSE
WHAT QUALIFIES AS HATE SPEECH,
ILLEGAL HATE SPEECH, WHICH YOU
WILL HAVE SOON IN THE U.S., WE
HAVE A STRONG REASON WHY WE HAVE
THIS IN THE CRIMINAL LAW.
>> KLAUS SCHWAB FROM THE WORLD
ECONOMIC FORUM AGREES BUT HE
WANTS YOU TO KNOW THAT ALL OF
THIS IS FOR YOUR OWN GOOD.
>> OUR ECONOMY IS UNDERGOING
DEEP TRANSFORMATION.
ENERGY, THE CONSEQUENCES OF
COVID, THE RESHAPING OF SUPPLY
CHAINS, ARE ALL SERVING AS
CATALYTIC FORCES FOR THE
ECONOMIC TRANSFORMATION.
THE MOST CRITICAL -- WILL BE
THOSE WHO TAKE A CONSTRUCTIVE
ATTITUDE, AND THOSE WHO ARE JUST
BYSTANDERS.
A SPIRIT OF DAVOS POSITIVE IS
CONSTRUCTIVE.
>> LAURA: WHEN HE SAYS -- WHAT
HE REALLY MEANS IS DIFFERING
OPINION.
AND THE DAVOS CROWD WANTS NONE
OF THAT BECAUSE THE ELITES WHO
WANT TO REORDER SOCIETY, THEY
ARE ALWAYS POSITIVE.
ALWAYS CONSTRUCTIVE, AND ANY WHO
DISAGREE WITH WHAT IT WILL
REQUIRE TO ACHIEVE THIS
SUSTAINABLE, GREENER PLANET,
YOU'RE ALWAYS DESTRUCTIVE.
NEGATIVE.
VERY NEGATIVE.
YET THE DEFLECTORS AND THE PRESS
CORE AREN'T INTERESTED IN THE
TRUTH BECAUSE IF THEY WERE THEY
WOULD BE DIGGING INTO THIS
VISION OF A CLEANER MORE
EQUITABLE WORLD.
AND WHILE WE'RE AT IT WHY SHOULD
WE ASSUME PURE MOTIVES ON THE
PART OF THE WORLD ECONOMIC FORUM
PANELISTS.
KLAUS SCHWAB DOES SOUND LIKE A
VILLAIN.
IF SOMEONE LIKE ESG CHAMPION
LARRY FINK CONSTANTLY MAKES
EXCUSES FOR AND DEFENDS CHINA,
WHERE THEY LITERALLY ENSLAVE
RELIGIOUS MINORITIES AND
DISSENTERS, WHY SHOULD WE LISTEN
TO ANYTHING HE SAYS.
>> EVEN IN THE FIRST LETTER,
WHEN I TALKED ABOUT DE
CARBONIZATION AND CLIMATE, THAT
WAS IN 2020, ALL THE THINGS I
HAVE SAID ARE STILL TRUE TODAY.
IF YOU DO NOT HAVE A LENS TOWARD
DE CARBONIZATION YOU AREN'T
GOING TO WIN ONE EURO OF
BUSINESS.
A, TRANSITION ALWAYS HAS TO BE
FAIR AND TRUST.
>> LAURA: HOW DID LARRY GET TO
DAVOS, BY THE WAY IN HIS SOLAR
JET?
AND HOW DOES LARRY RUN HIS
OFFICES?
WITH WIND POWER?
HE FAN SIS HIMSELF THE
SELF-APPOINTED MOYALIST.
HIS JOB GETS SHIPPED TO CHINA,
HE CAN'T AFFORD A DAY AT DISNEY,
LET ALONE A WEEK AT DAVE VORAX
AND LET'S FORGET THE GLOBALISTS
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN PARTIAL TO
EUROPE, BECAUSE, LET'S FACE IT,
TECHNOCRATS ESSENTIALLY RUN THE
E.U.
THE PEOPLE HAVE LIMITED SAY.
THEY ARE SLOW TO RESIST AGENDAS
FORCED UPON THEM LIKE MERKEL'S
DECISION TO FLOOD THE REGION
WITH AN INFLUX OF ISLAMIC
REFUGEES.
NOT POPULAR, THEY DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT, AND, OF
COURSE, DAVOS ATTENDEES LOVE
CHINA.
THEY DON'T CARE IF THEY ARE THE
WORLD'S BIGGEST POLLUTER AND
CHINA CONTINUES TO BUILD COAL
PLANTS.
IN FACT, THEY SEE THE CCP AS A
VERY VALUABLE PARTNER.
>> SINCE CHINA, REFORMED PROCESS
OVER 40 YEARS AGO, THE COUNTRY
HAS MADE GREAT CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE ECONOMY.
>> CHINA IS THE NUMBER ONE
DRIVER OF CLEAN ENERGY TO DATE.
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
>> YES.
>> WE VOW TO COOPERATE WITH THEM
OBVIOUSLY.
>> LAURA: WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO
COOPERATE WITH THEM.
THEY COMPLETELY IGNORE THE FACT
THAT SINCE CHINA WAS ADMITTED TO
THE WORLD TRADE ORGANIZATION
THEY HAVE BECOME IF ANYTHING
MORE, NOT LESS OPPRESSIVE.
BUT OF COURSE, NONE OF THAT
MATTERS TO THE ELITES.
THEN THERE IS AMERICA.
NOW, WE'RE BY OUR NATURE REBELS.
WE TEST THEORIES.
WE CHALLENGE HYPOTHESES.
WE QUESTION MOTIVES.
OUR FOUNDERS FOUND THAT FREE
INQUIRY WAS NEEDED AND WE HAD TO
PROTECT IT IN ORDER FOR US TO
REMAIN FREE AND AN INDEPENDENT
NATION.
IN A WORLD OF SHEEP, WE'VE BEEN
SHEPHERDS.
WE GO OUR OWN WAY TO PROTECT OUR
FLOCKS.
AND WHEN PUSH COMES TO SHOVE, WE
WON'T HESITATE GENERALLY TO
SHOVE THE ELITES AGAINST THE
WALL IF THEY START ENCROACHING
ON OUR FREEDOM.
BUT WITH BIDEN IN THE WHITE
HOUSE THE DAVOS CROWD THINKS
THEY HAVE AN OPENING.
HE'S THEIR USEFUL IDIOT.
BUT THEY KNOW THEY MAY HAVE ONLY
A TWO-YEAR WINDOW TO CO-OPT
AMERICA AND ADVANCE THEIR
INITIATIVES.
>> WE HAVE TO SAVE THIS PLANET
TO SAVE OUR FREEDOM AND THE WAY
WE'RE LIVING.
AND WE'RE NOT GOOD ENOUGH YET.
WE HAVE TO IMPROVE.
>> I FEEL THAT, YOU WERE TALKING
ABOUT DEVELOPMENT, I THINK
INDEED WE DON'T NEED LIKE GROWTH
OR DEVELOPMENT.
I REALLY THINK LESS IS MORE, AND
I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT.
>> LAURA: NO MORE DEVELOPMENT.
NONE FOR YOU.
NO MORE GROWTH.
IT'S BACK TO THE STONE AGE.
WELL, BENEATH ALL THEIR
BREATHLESS BLASTER ABOUT
SUSTAINABILITY AND GLOBAL
EQUITY, LIES THE TRUTH ABOUT THE
GLOBALIST'S REAL GOALS.
LOOK, WE'RE NOT EXPERIENCING A
PLANETARY EMERGENCY.
THEY ARE EXPERIENCING A POWER
EMERGENCY, MEANING, THEIRS IS IN
JEOPARDY.
PROTECTING THEIR OWN PURCHASE IN
INFLUENCE AND MONEY,
CONSOLIDATING THEIR POWER BY ANY
MEANS NECESSARY IS THEIR AIM.
SO YOUR MODES OF TRANSPORTATION,
YOUR FOOD SOURCES, HOW YOU COOK
YOUR FOOD, YOUR RIGHT TO
SELF-DEFENSE, YOUR RIGHT TO FREE
SPEECH, EVEN YOUR RIGHT TO OWN
PROPERTY, WOULD BE SACRIFICED
FOR THE GREATER GOOD.
BUT JUST REMEMBER THIS.
KLAUS AND THE GANG'S GREATEST
HITS ARE ONLY POPULAR AMONG A
SMALL SLICE OF LEFT WING
FANATICS AND ELITES WHO FLY TO
DAVOS TO VIRTUE SIGNAL ON THE
WAY TO CAVIAR AND CRYSTAL.
IN TWO YEARS AMERICA WILL HAVE A
NEW LEADER WHO P